and we saw you I mean we love you as
these are your our Canadian djembe he
has Sports Illustrated ideas that you
are on fire you look absolutely amazing
how was the experience for you how did
you find out tell us the shoot was a
relaxing with time we want to know
everything about you it's pretty
incredible thank you
I was so honored to be a part of that
obviously and I was very nervous before
because I had never done a bikini type
of shoot like that before and so it
started off we shot early in the morning
as we do for the Sun and so like makeup
at 5:00 a.m. I get out to the beach at
6:00 and they're like all right first
shot of the day take your top off and
like I was like what yeah what did I
just get myself into
and so that was I was very nervous at
but it actually helped because I kind of
got rid of the nerves right away and I
go by the end of the day I was like well
it's so comfortable you know we can do
anything guys I think it turned out okay
and I was just so fun as a person Caicos
it really how did you find out about it
I well we know these things kind of a
lot in advance okay I was earlier in the
summer before I did a shoot a bit later
and all students yeah and it was just so
excited and nervous and yeah and that
the issue also has been used Venus
Williams in it had Serena Serena and
yeah Dena Serena Serena yes and she's
pregnant I get a chance to connect with
her since she well I haven't seen she
hasn't been on tour yeah obviously she
announced she was pregnant but I think
she's giving birth really soon yeah I
can't wait to see the baby looks like
any one baby should be mean to you
I imagine so you never know the great
days thank you one of the things that to
say my girls and I love watching you
every time you're on they have to sit
down and watch you play you were on fire
and they have to ask you about that when
they played against Maria Sharapova you
were killing it and there's something
different about you
chances at that point what was it like
for you to have that wind it was a big
one for me because I had never beaten
her before and then obviously you know
with I guess you could say the
controversy around it it was kind of a
big moment and here I really just wanted
to kind of back myself up you know after
you know forcing my opinions on the
situation and so yeah it just gave me
some confidence that's good I think I
couldn't talk to each other since then
no I you know I love the way you're on
social media with your hand
- you're so good with that and and of
course that whole story above a Super
Bowl and going out with John I am one of
the University of Illinois marketing
student are you going to go out with him
again you so cute he actually is cute I
was one of us on the day some of my
friends are texting me like oh my God
he's actually so cute he is helping is
younger than me though although oh hi
I'm 23 news 20 I thought it wouldn't
bail again he's gonna be trying to free
people did only about like a cougar a
little bit but so there was a chance
we've kept in touch a little bit and
texting and snapchat so okay and you
were in Puerto Rico in February Zen
right I will get in have a bathroom for
you
that was a vacation trip beautiful but
you know we don't have opportunities
during the season to do that too much so
the summer I've had no chance to do
anything because we feel special
we're not talking about that
no special Inca is not putting me on the
spot that's right
that one okay this is yes I don't know
no tell me you didn't tell me it isn't
yet let's do this one well then that I'm
giving away my answer
nobody's you know it can be between you
and me that yeah I'll tell you that Oh
tell me later I can tell you guys about
that but you know the bad thing you had
a chance to do then you're focusing
right now but here we are entertaining
and pretty a fund a very smart water we
are entertaining we are anticipating
it's going to be so much fun but if you
could get your cell phone right now and
invite someone special someone cool on
your phone who would it be and invite
Jake her nieces drink you're in town in
Toronto just goes yeah exactly yeah
they're in the six you know should we
just text him right now and ask him all
right okay what's your phone texting
right away I like Drake of course these
are Canadian homeboys are I love them